من يومين تناولنا خبر الزياره المفاجئه
للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدنسي وتكلمنا عن بعض تفاصيل الزياره
الدراميه اللي استمرت ساعات محدوده فقط
وكانت قبل ايام من الذكرى السنويه لبدايه
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ومن التفاصيل
الدراميه اللي تكلمنا عنها انه البيت
الابيض نفاي زياره لبايدن وكان نشر جدول
اعمال وهمي للرئيس كان بيقول انه في
واشنطن وفي وقت هو وصل في بولندا واخذ
قطار عشر ساعات من ورسو لكييف هذا غير انه
تم السماح لصحفيين اثنين بس يرافقوا
الرئيس واخذوا منهم هواتفهم لمده 24 ساعه
وخلوهم كمان يقسموا على الحفاظ على السريه
امس زادت التفاصيل الدراميه من بعد ما نشر
الكسندر كمشين الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
السكك الحديديه الاوكرانيه عده تغريدات
كشف فيها عن بعض التفاصيل الجديده فنشر في
الاولى تغريده عنوانها بانه هذه قصه زياره
الرئيس الامريكي لكياب وكيف ولد القطار
الرئاسي وقال انه زياره بايدن كانت لحظه
تاريخيه وانه كان هو له الشرف هو وكل
فريقه انه عمله على تنسيقها وانها كانت
معقده جدا وكشف انه من اصل 24 ساعه بايضا
امضاء اكثر او امضى عشر ساعات بطريقه
الذهاب وعشر ساعات في الاياب يعني عشرين
ساعه في القطار واربع ساعات فقط في كييف
واعتذر للناس عن الخريطه اللي صارت او
الخربطه عفوا مشاهدينا عن اللي خربط اللي
صارت في جداول القطارات يومتها وقال انه
اضطروا ياجلوا رحلات عشان يتيحوا لقطار
بايدن السفر وانه لهذا السبب 90% بس من
قطارات هذاك اليوم
في وقتها المحدد وفق الجدول